das ist ziemlich mysteriös was da jetzt
im weltraum in unserer nachbarschaft
entdeckt wurde ein hell strahlen des
kompaktes objekt das forschende selbst
als gruselig beschreiben dieses seltsame
etwas sendet etwa dreimal in der stunde
massenhaft energie in richtung erde und
das bis zu einer minute lang wie ein
uhrwerk was könnte also dieses uhrwerk
sein die zum science and future games
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
laut der fachleute ist das ungewöhnliche
objekt am nachthimmel
anders als alles was wir kennen sein
verhalten beschreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weiterhin als gruselig spooky und zwar
nicht ohne grund ganz einfach deswegen
weil es am himmel nichts uns bekannt es
gibt das so etwas macht so die
astronomen der tasche hölle walker die
diesen mysteriösen himmelskörper mit
entdeckt hat es handelt sich um eine der
hellsten radio quellen am himmel und
zwar etwa drei mal pro stunde sendet sie
strahlung aus alle 18 minuten dann wirkt
dieses ungewöhnlich objekt wie ein zitat
himmlischer leuchtturm für etwa eine
minute lang äusserst crazy also vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass sich dieser
himmelskörper quasi in direkter nähe zu
unserer erde befindet zumindest in
kosmischen maßstäben
gesehen mit nur etwa 4000 lichtjahren
entfernung handelt es sich quasi um
einen nachbarn in unserem galaktischen
hinterhof astronomen und astronomen
weltweit zerbrechen sich den kopf worum
handelt es sich bei diesem rätselhafte
objekt und kann mit seiner hilfe
möglicherweise sogar eine
astrophysikalische theorien erklärt
werden alle infos die es bislang zu
diesem seltsamen himmelskörper gibt
bekommt ihr jetzt hier vermerkt
eigentlich sind objekte am himmel die an
und ausgehen für astronomen und das nur
um nichts unbekanntes variationen die
gelegentlich und unregelmäßig auftreten
werden in der fachsprache als transient
bezeichnet bekannt sind vor allem solche
objekte bei denen das sehr schnell in
sekunden sekundenbruchteilen oder
langsam also über mehrere tage oder
monate hinweg passiert zu nennen sind
hier beispielsweise supernovae die zwar
plötzlich beginnen aber über tage und
wochen anhalten auch über pulsare haben
wir hier bei pixum sich schon öfter
berichtet hierbei handelt es sich um
überreste von massereichen sternen die
sich hunderte male pro sekunde um die
eigene achse dreht dabei senden sie
stark gebündelte radiowellen aus und
diese werden sichtbar eben weil die
pulse sich drehen solche pulsare blitzen
in millisekunden oder sekunden rhythmus
auf ähnlich ist das bei fast religiös
fab sie gehören wohl zu den
rätselhaftesten phänomen des kosmos
diese ultra kurzen radio bild zu setzen
so viel energie frei wie unsere sonne an
einem ganzen tag und das achtung in nur
wenigen millisekunden
ex bereits viele phänomene sind der
fachwelt bekannt die kurzlebige oder
periodische radiowellen schübe erzeugen
weitere beispiele sind rotierende
neutronensterne
veränderliche sterne und
sternenexplosionen doch die spektakuläre
entdeckung des australischen
forschungsteams passt in keine dieser
kategorien
astronomen gastronom um die
wissenschaftler in der tasche hatte
walker haben radio pulse aus 4000
lichtjahren entfernung aufgespürt die
wirklich ganz außergewöhnlich sind ihre
variation star passt zu keiner der
bisher bekannten kosmischen fällen
eingefangen wurden im mysteriösen
signale von dem radioteleskop merchants
in wide field
in westaustralien dieses teleskop
besteht aus vielen eher klein und
starren antennen vor zwei jahren 2020
fand mit der hilfe des radioteleskops
die bislang breiteste suche auf
vergleichsweise niedrigen frequenzen
nach außerirdischen lebens statt
mindestens zehn millionen sterne wurden
genauer ins visier genommen auch das
zentrum unserer milchstraße wurde mit
dem cabrio im radiobereich kartiert die
neue entdeckung gelang eher zufällig und
zwar dem damaligen studenten teilen oder
hort er konnte das bizarre objekt
aufspüren und zwar mit daten aus dem
jahr 2018 das aus das forschungsteam
hatte archivierte daten des teleskops
noch einmal genauer ins visier genommen
und dabei einen neu entwickelten such
algorithmus genutzt dazu sagt agon oder
heute es ist aufregend dass sich die
quelle die ich letztes jahr intensiv ii
ziert habe als ein so eigenartiges
objekt herausgestellt hat dass große
sichtfeld und die extreme
empfindlichkeit des mdr sind perfekt um
den gesamten engel zu vermessen und das
unerwartete zu entdecken in den daten
von januar und februar 2018 machten die
fachleute also eine spannende entdeckung
insgesamt 71 energiereiche radio pulse
die alle aus derselben quelle stammt und
dass eben aus unserer nähe im sternbild
norma zum vergleich der durchmesser der
milchstraße liegt bei etwa 100.000
lichter und diese quelle ist nur 4000
lichtjahre entfernt laut der aktuellen
studie die jetzt im renommierten
fachmagazin nature veröffentlicht wurde
handelt sie sich um ein hell strahlen
des kompaktes objekt dieses ist wohl
kleiner als die sonne und sendet
polarisiertes licht aus nach ansicht der
fachleute könnte das ein hinweis auf ein
starkes magnetfeld seien vor allem das
pulse muster dieser radio quelle raubt
astronomen astronom weltweit im schlaf
denn die radio pulse wiederholen sich in
einem abstand von 18 minuten und waren
es 30 16 sekunden lang damit liegt
dieses blinkt muster genau zwischen den
bislang bekannten langsamen und
schnellen transienten eine variation
minutenbereich also die laut der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
äußerst spooky also gruselig ist eine
aufregende und rätselhafte entdeckung
also dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
dies ist eine ungewöhnliche
periodizität die unseres wissens nach
noch niemals zuvor beobachtet worden ist
und mindestens genauso rätselhaft die
quelle dieser radio pulse sendet in zwei
jeweils 30 tage langen phasen und das
sehr regelmäßig wäre nur weg dazu heißt
es in der aktuellen studie immer dann
wenn wir die nächsten puls er war
treffer auch ein es gab keine ausfälle
zwischendurch zwischen diesen beiden
phasen aber gab es eine pause die 26
tage lang dauerte hier wurden keinerlei
pulse detektiert auch das ist für die
fachwelt bislang noch unerklärlich die
leitende astronomen hurley walker sagt
dazu für einen astronomen ist das fast
schon unheimlich denn es gibt an nichts
bekanntes dass sich so verhält
mittlerweile ist das objekt übrigens
nicht mehr aktiv doch die fachleute
gehen davon aus dass es jeden moment
wieder aufleuchten könnte doch fest
steht bislang war das objekt nur in den
ersten drei monaten des jahres 2008 sind
aktiv doch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler müssen dieses ergebnis
einschränken dazu heißt es wir haben
aufnahmen durchgeschaut die eigentlich
objekte in der umgebung untersuchten es
kann also sein dass wir die radio quelle
nur unvollständig abgedeckt habe die
große frage aber die über allem steht
was ist die ursache dieser rätselhaften
signale die fachwelt hat noch keine
abschließende erklärung allerdings gibt
es einige vermutungen und spekulationen
gerade signale sind nach analyse der
fachleute stark lenya polarisiert was
darauf hinweist dass die quelle ein
starkes magnetfeld aufweisen muss zudem
gegen die australischen forscherinnen
und forscher davon aus dass das objekt
klein und kompakt ist darauf lässt seine
helligkeitsverteilung schließen
möglicherweise rotiert die quelle auch
oder aber bewegt sich in einem orbit das
leiten die fachleute aus der
regelmäßigkeit der pulse her das
australische forschungsteam spekuliert
in der aktuellen studie ob
möglicherweise ein stark magnetisiert
weißer zwerg oder aber einen
neutronenstern die merkwürdigen radio
pulse aussendet wenn diese rotieren und
über ein starkes magnetfeld verfügen
kann es zur freisetzung von radio
strahlung an den polen kommen diese
kommen dann auf der erde als radio pulse
doch gegen diese erklärung möglichkeit
spricht das bisher bekannte pulsare und
magnetare puls perioden von weniger als
10 sekunden aufweisen oder ist der
urheber der signale etwa ein sogenannter
ultra periodisch haben agnetha ein sehr
langsam rotierenden neutronenstern also
der bislang allerdings nur theoretisch
vorhergesagt werden konnte beobachtet
werden konnte ein solches objekt bislang
noch nie ist das also die spannende
premiere dazu sagt natascha hurley
walker die existenz solcher langsam
rotierende neutronensterne wurde bereits
theoretisch vorhergesagt aber keiner hat
erwartet ein solches objekt direkt
detektieren zu können weil sie als nicht
sonderlich strahlungs intensiv gelten
mehr solche funde könnten uns verraten
ob es sich um ein einmaliges ereignis
handelte oder um den ersten vertreter
einer ganzen population
wandeln solche magnetare also ihre
magnetische energie besonders effizient
in radiostrahlung um das australische
forschungsteam liegt auf der lauer und
wartet sehnsüchtig darauf dass das
objekt wieder aktiv wird dazu wird es
engmaschig von den fachleuten überwacht
gleich mehrere teleskope würden es dann
sofort anvisieren die australischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hoffen zudem in den archiv daten des
mädchens und wild cherry weitere
radiowellen aufzuspüren das wäre dann
tatsächlich die entdeckung einer ganzen
neuen klasse von himmelskörpern
und es gibt noch mehr sehr seltsame
radiowellen fachwelt verwundert
unerklärliche radiosignale aus der
milchstraße eine ähnliche mysteriöse
entdeckung also anklicken anschauen und
nicht vergessen abonnieren das ist
kostenlos und geht mit dem abo button
unter jedem video bis dann bleibt dran